[Music]
hello everyone thank you so much for
coming to our talk this is MLA I 225
machine learning with tensor flow and PI
torch on apache hadoop using cloud data
proc so I'm Brad Murrow I'm a developer
programs engineer on Google cloud hi I'm
Alan Solow Gasca I'm also a developer
programs engineer in cloud so this is
Thursday morning you've probably seen
this slide a hundred times already but
we will be having a Dory accompanying
this talk so if at any point during the
talk you have any questions feel free to
just go into the Dory on the app ask the
questions
and then we'll be going through them at
the end and getting you the information
that you're looking for so what we're
gonna discuss today we will start by
discussing machine learning on Apache
Hadoop generally will then discuss cloud
data proc which is Google cloud
platforms managed Apache Hadoop and
Apache spark service will then discuss
distributed machine learning some
strategies for doing that how you can
actually solve this problem currently
and then we'll show you a demo of
running it tensorflow and PI torch on
cloud data proc so let's just dive right
into it but before we do that I just
want to survey the room very briefly who
here uses Apache Hadoop on a regular
basis just a quick show of hands awesome
what about who writes machine learning
algorithms on a regular basis just
another quick show of hands okay a few
more hands and lastly who uses
tensorflow and/or pipe torch on a
regular basis awesome ok cool so we'll
just start with a bit of a survey of
what the Hadoop and machine learning
ecosystems look like starting on the
left you have in the Hadoop ecosystem
you have your patchy hive your Apache
Pig your presto those are for of course
querying Hadoop for your data and then
you have Apache spark for running ETL
jobs and loading your data into memory
and of course the rich ecosystem that
comes with Apache spark specifically on
the right side on the machine learning
side of the Venn diagram you have your
packages such as extra boost and Psyche
Atlin and then of course in the deep
learning circle deep learning being a
subset of machine
we have tender flow PI torch and Karis
if we look at the intersection of the
two sides of the Venn diagram you'll
notice that we have spark ml Lib which
is very similar to scikit-learn for
those of you who may be familiar with
that for running machine learning models
on Hadoop but noticeably there's nothing
in this section here for doing a tensor
flow or PI torch so let's discuss how to
get there but why should you care of
course so you may already have an Apache
Hadoop cluster and you may have
pre-existing investments there and you
want to instead of spinning up new
infrastructure you may just want to run
your jobs there and see what some
potential models may look like you also
may have existing workflows for loading
data into and out of Hadoop and of
course if you have all of your machine
learning processing running on Apache
Hadoop you don't have to worry about the
workflows changing or and then you're
able to leverage them that way and then
of course being Apache Hadoop you are in
the world of distributed distributed
processing so of course you can leverage
that here as well so tend to flow and
pipe torch we're just going to go over
these briefly what they are as they're
mentioned in the title of course and
we're going to talk about them today so
tens are flow being an open source
machine learning framework that is
developed by Google it has access to
distributed machine learning so it is
built into the framework itself and
there's ways that you can do that it has
a very rich ecosystem of packages such
as tender flow extended for building
end-to-end machine learning pipelines as
well as tangible which is a nice UI for
actually seeing your models as it's
training and you can set the metrics on
there that you want to see including
accuracy or loss tensorflow also
utilizes Kerris as at eye level api for
those of you can have used carrots
before you know how user-friendly it is
and how in my opinion fun it is to use
so of course that is built right into
tensorflow and tender flow is also
perfectly suited for both production and
research so there's you know for all of
your needs you can utilize tender flow I
just want to do a quick shout out that a
tensor flow 2.0 alpha was just released
so if you're interested in learning more
about that check out tensor flow org and
you can get started playing around with
the 2.0 version and then of course we're
going to talk about
two pi torch is an open-source machine
learning framework that was developed by
Facebook PI towards also supports
distributed machine learning natively so
you have access to run those distributed
jobs using PI torch pipe search has
built-in model layers so there's classes
for things such as an RNN layer or a
convolutional neural network layer so
you have access to those just right out
of the box and then of course PI torch
is also perfectly suited for production
and/or research depending on your needs
so now that we've discussed machine
learning on Apache Hadoop let's discuss
Apache Hadoop as it pertains to Google
cloud platform and so our solution to a
managed patchy loop service is Cloud
Data proc and so what does cloud data
product it contains managed clusters for
Apache and Apache spark cloud data plot
allows you to deploy clusters in 90
seconds or less on average for very
quick up times when you're using cloud
data frac you only pay for the time that
your queries are running also known as
compute time it's perfectly suited to be
configurable with open source solutions
so of course we have Apache Hadoop we
have Apache spark we have a patchy Pig
Apache hive as well as what we call
optional components which are some of
your favorite open source data science
libraries that you can include with your
cluster when you spin it up so that
includes things such as anaconda JEP
Jupiter Zeppelin presto and there's a
whole long list of them that you can
find on our website and cloud data
Proctor has seamless integration with a
lot of GCP services including bigquery
and Google Cloud Storage connector
cloud composer also has a cloud of data
proc operator which makes spinning your
cluster up and down using cloud composer
super easy to do and then Cloud Data
proc also has the auto scaling feature
that is currently in beta and auto
scaling is a really nice feature we're
going to talk a little bit more about it
later in the session but the idea behind
it is that as your loads as the pressure
on your cluster increases or decreases
Cloud Data proc can actually add or
remove workers without you having to
manually go in and add them yourself you
can do that of course but this feature
allows you to not have to do that
so we'll just discuss a little bit more
about the architecture behind data
product this will
fairly high-level but we'll just give
you a little bit more of an insight so
starting on the left here you can see
that we have your networking and your I
am layers like you would for any other
TCP service in in our stack next you
have the cloud data product API and so
this is really awesome for actually
interfacing with your cluster you have
the ability to interact with the cluster
also via the UI but using the the cloud
commit console commands you can interact
with your cluster you also have access
to the jobs API which allows you to
preset what type of job you're
submitting so for instance if you're
submitting let's say a PI spark job data
proc you can set that when you submit
the command and then this way it'll you
a cloud data file pre-configure the
runtime environment for you and then you
also have access to your Hadoop and
spark operations via the data practic a
P I so you have access to all of those
tools do you okay and then of course
within the cluster itself so you have
your Cloud Data proc open source image
and so as I mentioned earlier that can
include your Apache spark your Apache
how do you protect you hive Apache Pig
and then there's the optional components
that I was mentioning as well so here we
have Jupiter Zeppelin and presto mention
but there's a whole list of them as I
mentioned earlier you can do anaconda
you can do our studio there's a whole
bunch of them and then of course being a
Hadoop cluster of course you can write
out to either HDFS or to Google Cloud
storage so now that we've discussed
machine learning at Apache Hadoop and
Google cloud platform solution to having
an Apache Hadoop service we're going to
talk about the street distributed
machine learning right now I think it's
all about something to save things right
so what is this triggered machine
learning and quite it's important in the
context of Hadoop I mean if you're a
machine learning engineer a data
scientist or you being experimenting
with deep learning models you probably
know like when you are training large
machine learning models they take very
long time so some of those may take like
a couple of hours some models take days
and they're like very large models that
may take even weeks to complete training
so the first the first application for
this real machine learning is try to
reduce this training time another
application for this to be machine
learning will be try to run experiments
in parallel so for example if you are
doing hyper parameter searching you can
run
a multiple Mossimo tenuously so you can
save some time so let's take a look at
how this journey looks like so normally
when you are still experimenting with
your deep learning models you can use
your local computer or a bit on machine
in the cloud and you start with a
multi-core CPU that might be okay for
like very small training models but if
you really want to take advantage and
reduce the training time you can't use
accelerators an accelerator could be a
TPU a GPU or an FPGA for this talk I'm
only gonna be referring to oscillators
as GPUs so what do you do you install
the drivers you attach your device and
if you're using like frameworks like
tensorflow or PI torch you need like
very little or no code modification to
start training your models if you can
attach one GPU I mean why not to attach
more GPUs again you touch more GPUs you
start doing your training and if you're
using a framework like tensorflow
there's something new in terms of flow
which is called distribution strategies
so with distribution strategies the goal
of the tensorflow api is like don't care
too much about the underlying
infrastructure so you just define what
is your underlying architecture so for
example if you are running a single node
you might just define like oh okay I
have two GPUs so you can continue adding
GPUs into your single node but at some
point you're gonna hit some hardware
limitations and from an architectural
perspective you need to instead of
scaling up you want to scale
horizontally right so the next obvious
step is going a multi node multiple GPUs
well multiple node and multiple GPUs
might help you reduce your training time
in reality you need to consider other
factors for example how's the
communication between the devices and
like neural network overhead between
those multiple nodes so when we talk
about distributed machine learning there
are like two main paradigms that we
always need to talk about
so the first paradigm is called data
parallelism so within a parallelism you
normally have your neural network or
your model and you store it locally and
then you start training your model with
different slices of data
so this could be synchronous or
asynchronous if it's a synchronous which
is like the traditional way of doing
tensor flow you normally train your
model differently slices of data and the
workers might be doing the heavy lifting
for example they will be they will be
computing all the gradients and your
parameter server or like another another
server might be use doing the averaging
of the of those gradients that would be
like the asynchronous way and they're
like new techniques like new
distribution strategies for example a
mirror strategy which actually is called
synchronous where like all the devices
compute the gradients locally and they
communicate those directly or indirectly
to others they will be updating the
model only when when it's required
but sometimes your model is quite large
that you italica not fit it into one
device so if you think of like a neural
network you may need to split these
different layers into multiple devices
so tensorflow allows you to execute
different parts of the graph in
different in different devices
this is kamala parallelism so an example
of these models would be like wide and
deep anyone networks and one example is
the google a near on machine translation
model that's like a very large model so
this this is lightly sticking from the
tensorflow web page this is a training
model that the tenth floor team did so
basically what they did was they
collected four different models which
are very popular for benchmarking
inception B 3 B 16 resonate 50 and 152
and they trained them with different
GPUs 1 2 4 & 8 so what they actually
found is like the more GPUs that we
actually add the faster we can process
those images so you can see there's a
linear growth based on the number of
GPUs that we have and the faster we are
actually able to process those images
the the faster the training is is
actually happening but I mean what
happens when you go from research or
experimentation to production if there's
more than training right so you normally
have a pipeline and we have a berry I'm
gonna go through like a very simplified
I probably oversimplified a machine
learning pipeline and you could start
with data preparation so think about the
feature engineering or your regular ETL
process
well you are collecting your data you
are selecting which features you need
and normally in this case you know you
don't need a GP you probably you are
fine with will CPU cluster if you think
of like the apache echo system you will
be using apache spark on this one
once your if you collect your data and
it's ready to to be trained
you have your trained dealer now do you
move to a different stage which is like
the training data so we we just agree
that using accelerators is a good option
and you have access to those to those
devices in reality like if you work with
different departments or you are running
different experiments in your company
you probably need to be consider about
how do you use these devices right like
when you allocate a GPU when you
allocate other accelerator you need to
make sure that you need a resource
manager it's not like I'm just gonna be
configuring my my tensorflow webpage and
my terms of flow work and it's just
gonna be working so once you move from
from training you have a you have to sir
you go to the serving phase well you can
have a both of CPU and GPUs so if you
think of like serving you would use like
kubernetes maybe some docker containers
running tons of flows serving and you
will be fine maybe with CPU but if you
really want to increase the speed for
your inference you may be you may you
may want to add like EP use a good
example of like a GPU that is designed
only for inference would be like the
test lab t4 from Nvidia so we we agree
that when you use resources you need a
resource manager and there's already
like applications that solve this
problem I think about yarn think about
messes or kubernetes but how do you
configure actually tends to float to
have access to these devices right if in
the in the classical way for configuring
tensorflow
you normally define your cluster and you
define the IP addresses some ports which
are going to be running your tensorflow
code you might define your workers your
parameter servers then you stop and
yours you start your your servers based
on your on your job but this is
something like data scientists don't
really want to do or this is the very
folk
on dev operations there's something
called the F country which is an
environmental bearable that is designed
to address this problem so a lot of
resource manager like like you've
already supports this environmental
variable so basically you define a
cluster specification which you only
gonna be reading and then from there you
can execute your code so we're going to
go through some of the list of products
that actually already address this
problem like meaning a resource a
resource allocation and running
distributed machine learning workflows
who has who is familiar with some of
these products like you flow a platform
horrible tense prone spark was
productive learning anybody has used any
of these so one of the things that we
care in the in the context of this talk
is that it's supported on yarn right
it's it runs on Hadoop so the first the
first product is is queue flow so it's
based on a queue Benares environment so
this might not be a good option the
second one is a our platform is probably
previously known as cloud machine
learning engine I will change the name
and this is great for model training in
France and model versioning but it's a
hosted solution by Google so you really
don't care about the infrastructure so
we just bring your model and we do the
we handle the infrastructure for you the
other one is a horrible it's more like a
library so horribly celebrity by uber so
what about the problem that was trying
to solve is run running distributed
machine learning on top of ten to flow
to be able to speed up the the training
time and it doesn't really run some had
to be smaller more like a helper and
then we have to products tend to flow
and spark from Yahoo which was one of
the best of the of the first solutions
for this to try to address this problem
so tend to flow on the spark runs runs
on two different layers the spark layer
and then the tenth floor lay the
tensorflow layer disparate layer and the
yarn layer from this do you rely on this
part to do the resource allocation
then you need to pass that request to
yarn so you need like very little code
modification and it works right from
some group flows the other one is
suspected deep learning from their
breaks so it follows the same paradigm
and it integrates very good with the ml
flow ecosystem from their breaks but one
of the things that we actually carries
is GPU support so when we think of GPU
support in Hadoop if we're you seeing
there's something like we need to
mention so Hadoop version 3.1 is the
version that in reality supports GPU
allocation this means like when you are
attaching a GPU to your devices resource
manager in Hadoop is aware that you have
a GPU connected before Hadoop 3.1
there's another workaround which is
using node labels so basically you tack
your servers that have a GPU so when you
run your jobs
you basically route that job to the
servers that have a GPU already but it's
not like native support for epu one of
the problems with this is that when you
use it turns from spark or spark deep
learning is that you have a layer on top
which is a spark so this part also
requires to be able to be aware of the
GPUs and there's already some work in
the spark community I think as / - I
know it's going to be supporting this
but they're still idea open for this
issue so that's why it's important to if
we really want to take advantage of the
GPU hub a native yarn support so then it
comes Tony what is Tony Tony is a
project which stands for tends to flow
yarn although it also supports by Church
so the main functionality for Tony is
orchestrate distribute intensive flow or
byte or jobs in yarn but it also
supports single jobs so you can bring
your single node job and execute
executed on on Hadoop
it's a it was developed by Lincoln and
it was open source back last summer
so what are the important things about
Tony so Tony is is gonna be supporting
first-class jobs from running Hadoop
this means like when you run a tends to
float you of or byte or job it's gonna
be the same as as you were running on
Sparky of this just running on the same
level if you're ready invested in in
Hadoop and all your infrastructure but
you want to start experimenting with
deep learning we want you to use me to
minify your infrastructure up a little
so your data scientist and machine
engineers can start to using the product
so Tony it's allows you to have a client
and we're gonna go more into details
you're gonna you're gonna have a client
that you're gonna be using to to execute
your jobs and one of the features from
Tony is that you can request resources
in a very fine-grain a manner this means
like if you have a tensile float your pi
torch you can request how much memory
from how many cores are gonna be using
and how many GPUs and jobs require very
little parameters so normally when you
execute a Python script you have a
patron environment with all your
libraries and you have your Python
Python files right so what does I think
we need you need a configuration file so
as little as three options you can
actually execute a Tony job over there
like other possibilities and if you're
running long training jobs you want to
make sure that those you abstract early
complete successfully so when you launch
a Tony job you need to be able to verify
that all your workers are executing
correctly and if some of your containers
actually fail you need to be able to
restart it so let's take a look at the
Tony architecture the first thing that
when you want to run a tensorflow job or
Pytor job that you need to ring is your
code right so you bring your code and
the second thing is you need to bring
your visual environment so the build
environment is going to be in in a sip
format or like
compress and finally your configuration
which is the resources that you actually
need so this configuration is an XML
file that you can define where you
when you have like CPU how many how much
memory you require for each of the
workers how many you PEP use you need so
those three things that are the first
the first part of running a job then you
need the Tony client so Tony client is a
jar file that is compiled using Gradle
so Tony is built on on Yaba so when you
launch Tony when you're gonna be
launching a Tony job you execute the job
and it's gonna contact Yahoo yarn Hadoop
yarn and it's gonna spin off a container
so this is the application master
container so application master
container is gonna see what you
configure and negotiate the resources
with yarn so for example if you
negotiate three workers it's going to
try to allocate resources for those
three workers that's the second element
of of Tony then you have your task
executors so that's executors is
actually your machine learning code that
is executing and those are those are
based on their resources that you
requested so those aren't containers so
task executors is gonna be your machine
learning code that is actually executing
so we have talked a lot about different
topics but do you think it's time for a
demo I think it is I think we should
show our audience a little bit about how
to run tensorflow
on a platform okay so I know you were we
were discussing before before this talk
that you had actually set up a cloud
data posture do you mind telling us how
you may have done it sure
creating the wrapper closer is very
simple so the first thing that you need
to use is you can use the G cloud
command or you can use the UI if you're
gonna use the g-cloud command you just
need to define your cluster name and the
number of workers this would be your
node managers in Hadoop
then we can take advantage of a feature
called initialization action which are
Shella scripts that are going to be
execute during cluster creation time in
this case we have two the Tony
shall scrip and the GPU drivers that
initial script what it's gonna do is
gonna clone the code from the github
repo and it's going to be off the ER
file for Tony in the official shell
script we also provide two samples
we tend to flow and one with Python code
that you can actually use in the second
shell script what we do is because we
want to use GPUs we need to install the
drivers and we need to set up a service
at stackdriver service that is going to
be monitoring the GPU utilization in
this case we're going to be using two EP
use so for each of the workers we're
going to be attaching a tesla big
hundred bu and because we want to run
many many jobs we want to enable out the
scaling policy awesome well thank you
for telling us that I think we should
now run some jobs okay right so where's
yours we switch to the demo fees thank
you perfect so we created a cluster in
advance this has two workers let's go to
the instances you can see here there's
the master node and then the two workers
with each of those who has a GPU so
let's run some jobs I'm gonna be running
one tends to float job to start wait
you're only gonna run one well now we
have auto scaling enable we can do more
maybe two how about ten okay and let's
do a Python Java also for good measure
okay perfect so I created a script that
is gonna be launching those tensorflow
jobs and let's take a look at this
script
so I'm using the G cloud command to run
the the tensorflow code so in this case
we're submitting a Hadoop job in the
cluster that we just created the Tony
client is just a jar file so we define
the ER file here and because you said
you have a file we just need to define
the class one feature for tony's also
not only allows you to run Python code
but you can also run notebooks like
simple in notebooks or you can you can
even run docker containers the only
requirement is that your hadoop
infrastructure is ready for docker so in
this case we're actually running Python
code so when we were talking about how
Tony is minimalistic in terms of
executing codes executing code one of
the things that as you can see try to
emulate is if you're a data scientist
you normally run a Python command like
this right you have a built on
environment you live in a source
directory and then you run Python and
your Python file and because this is
machine learning code you should be able
to pass some parameters so this is
sucked like what actually Tony require
so here you pass the baton environment
this is your sip bit while environment
you past execute the Python executable
and then your your script in case you
have more of more files by defining the
source directory you should be able to
get all those dependencies so what is
that M distributed PI job what is that
actually going to be doing so in this
case what we're going to be doing is
we're going to run the hello world for
machine learning about distributed where
we're going to be using the M niece that
I said so it's a convolutional network
for de detection okay cool and finally
we have the configuration file
so this is how your Tony configuration
file looks like in this case we're going
to be spinning off two workers this is
the requirements for memory we're going
to be using one parameter server this is
a requirement for our parameter server
and why GPU so let's take a look how
this how this looks in yarn wait a
minute I'd ask for a Python job but I
haven't seen any Python okay so let's
get some fighters in here so in order to
run this byte or job we're going to be
using the data proc API so the approach
allows you to run to submit Python code
very similar as you do the g-cloud
command but from the from the API
directly so what I'm doing is just
importing the data proc API I'm defining
my project so in this case you can see
my Prague ID my region and this is the
Toni client so it's a jar file so we
talked about like how they're approached
by default has the GCS connector so you
can actually without any configuration
have access to your G cloud-to-cloud
pocket so this is like using the latest
and Tony version which is 0 3.1 we
define the class this is just a helper
function and this is how it normally
looks in the indie cloud command that we
just launched but we're gonna do it from
the client so you define your job
controller your arguments you create
your Hadoop job and then you're gonna
define where which cluster you're gonna
send this job and now we just send the
job let's take a look at their approach
for all these jobs
let me go to the cluster so it's subtly
easier so here are our ten jobs and this
is just the Python job that we just
create and you can see that one job
already completed we can use the
monitoring tab and there's a lot of
memory being used that is actually
pending do you think out the scaling is
gonna work absolutely we just get the
slide back please
so let's just talk about out of scaling
really quickly and how you can enable it
that on the cluster so Gonzalo was
showing you before how here we have the
auto scaling policy that we've called
Auto scale Tony and what that actually
looks like is it's just a llamo file
that gets uploaded to Google cloud here
you can see that there's only two
top-level components we have the worker
config and D basic algorithm so we'll
just discuss what those are we'll start
with the worker config you'll see here
that we have two parameters set we have
the minute instances and the max
instances respectively set to two and
ten what this means is that as auto
scaling is adding and removing workers
to the cluster it will always make sure
that the total number of workers is
within these two numbers inclusively so
this will never have less than two
workers and never more than ten and how
does it actually figure out how many
workers that should add so it uses the
basic algorithm for that and here we've
set the the time to check to be two
minutes so as we've denoted by the
cooldown period so every two minutes
it'll look at the available men memory
that's the available memory and the the
pending memory and then it'll calculate
how many workers it sure to add and then
once it comes up with that number it
will then multiply it by either the
scale up or the scale down factor
depending on what how many workers and
thinks it should add and remove and so
what this number does is gives you some
more fine-grained control as to how
quickly you may want the cluster to
scale up or scale down in this case
we've set these both to 1.0 which means
that the cluster will attempt to have as
near perfect memory utilization as
possible but in the event that you don't
care about that and if there's a spike
in your pending memory you don't
necessarily need to have a bunch of
clusters added you can scale this number
down and let's say 0.5 or 0.1 just
completely dependent on whatever your
use cases so you have the option
there then last but not least we have
the graceful decommission timeout and
what this value does is if your cluster
determines that it should take down some
of the workers it'll actually set in
this case a 15-minute lag to it so that
in case there's any jobs that are
currently running you wouldn't want the
you wouldn't want the cluster to just
take the workers down and have those
those jobs disappear on you so just a
small anecdote Gonzalo and I were
recently working on a project where we
were using the auto scaling feature and
we had that happen to us where the the
data was simply the jobs were just
failing and we never configure this so
it was just alright believed we had set
this to zero minutes and then the jobs
were just failing so we added this and
of course that perfectly perfectly
solved our problem so that's auto
scaling let's see maybe do we have any
more workers we started with to
hopefully there's more than two let's
take a look can we go back to the demo
again perfect so maximize ease so this
is the yarn UI you can see that this
cobbler was very busy and some of the
jobs still running and other us are
still waiting to be to get resources I
see that Python shop yeah and this is we
were saying like the application type
Tony is a native native of yarn so each
of these jobs requires like 12 gigabytes
of RAM to workers for Jia bits each plus
the parameter server to close the
application container which is an r2
that's 12 total so you can also monitor
the utilization here in India proc but
looks like something is happening let's
take a look you can see here how the
cluster it's being scaling up which is
very good I see there's three workers
that's great
yep you can see here this as well
perfect but let's see how did you up
start doing good so what I'm gonna do is
just make sure like my cubes are fully
completed correctly so you can pick any
of the jobs and see the configuration
and these are the exact parameters that
we pass when we create the job and we
created one key identifier just for the
sake of having an ID and you can see
here all our test parameters so we are
training the model with 750 steps so I'm
gonna be launching tensor birth to see
that this is just an script that
launches ten to ten support locally but
the data as you guys saw in the in the
training job let me go back here the
directly leaps in energy cloud storage
bucket so we didn't need to configure
anything just out of the box okay so
let's see if ten support it's running oh
good so this was trained for 750 steps
and as you can see the more steps that
are actually executing the accuracy
keeps increasing and cross-entropy loss
it's reducing as well this is a
completion on network so you can see
here all the graph and the node
that are connected except they cool to
point out here is that using Tony on
Apache Hadoop you have access to the
full suite of Ted's aboard of features
so as Gonzalo is showing you so I think
that that's a really nice feature to
have tens of our being as useful as it
is and this helpful as it is for
training your models and it looks like
our jobs are are doing pretty well yep
cool so I think in the interest of time
we'll just wrap up but you'll see that
we have five of them finishing and if we
were to give this more time of course
these will continue to run if we can
just go back to the slides please
awesome so we'll just close out and just
quickly recap what we what we discussed
today what we showed you so we started
off by discussing machine learning on
Apache hoop and what that looks like
what the current landscape for that is
we then discussed an introduced cloud
data park to you as Google cloud
platforms managed Apache Hadoop and
Apache spark service we then discussed
distributed machine learning and some of
the options and strategies for doing
that and then of course we introduced
Tony to you and showed you a demo of how
you can get started using Tony and we
used cloud data pack as our means to
show you that so if you're interested in
learning more about this the here's the
link for the actual Tony repo itself
it's github.com forward slash linked-in
forward slash tony CEO and why also if
you have any questions feel free to add
your questions to stack overflow under
the Tony tag and you know we'll be happy
to answer you and then for the code that
we showed today we're actually gonna be
sharing that over Twitter in the next
couple of days so feel free to follow us
on Twitter Gonzalo at GOG ACSA and
myself that'd be our admi ro Brad Mario
and yeah so thank you everyone for
coming just a quick shout out to the
where you wanna just thank the cloud
data proc team the LinkedIn team as well
as the producers in the room and also
all of our friends who were super
helpful in helping us out with this
[Music]